my god
laughs mr. torque and I love you and I
am sorry Merlin gentlemen archaeologist
we hear you're planning a trip to Elvis
Pandora's moon just so you know you're
up gonna die
but it'll still be totally awesome
Altus is a most controversial locale
you'll see between the events of
Borderlands and Borderlands 2 the man
who would eventually become handsome
jack higher or vault hunters to save
mankind from a brand new evil these
escapades are chronicled in Borderlands
the pre-sequel which is an invited word
denoting both prequel and secret site
spare
every day you've likely killed many
things on Pandora already but things are
quite different up here on Elvis for
realsies yes
for realsies the gravity is even lower
so you can job extremely high into the
atmosphere for acrobatic gunfights
additionally if you have an oxygen kit
or and all's kit as the locals refer to
them you can slam down from great
heights to squish your enemies to death
this maneuver is called a gravity slam
do not call it a butt slam you can also
find a grated ostrich that add elemental
damage to your slabs like fire a shot
for acid or exposing or I have changed
my mind you can call it a punch leg
looks swear but that's not all oz kids
can do you know what's better than
jumping cuddling with someone you love
very much
you know it's almost as awesome as that
double jumping double jumping allows you
to reach all new areas let's reverse the
environment with greater freedom than
you ever had on Pandora but oz kids are
the only who you'll find on Elpis
westberry
I know how much you like loot because we
are best friends and I put your deed
before my own well said mr. talk Pandora
has 87 bazillion guns but Elvis has he
take the new cryo weapons for instance
for the first time ever you can freeze
an enemy with cryo damage which will
immobilize them and make them
oscillations this once you've done
enough damage to them they shall shatter
into tiny little ice shards for me
you're too cool for freeze weapons maybe
you're more about blasting stuff with a
science lucky for you now this is
chock-full of laser weapons you want to
help go somebody with the flats arrival
you can't do that you are a fire massive
railgun black and kills a bad guy in one
hit now problem that's helped us even as
laser shotgun laser shotguns you're
welcome
not only back but sizes even made of
continuous laser beam that looks just
like the one from that movie Ghost and
and if you get a piece of loot you don't
like you can always toss it into the
brand new grinder machine put less
awesome things into the grinder grind
them up and get something moderately
more awesome but who will be using all
this loot you ask easy for brand new
vault hunters a cyborg mercenary a gun
slinging sadist an annoying robot and a
deadly gladiator generate quality will
honed the enforcer uses his - surveyor
drones to tear up the battlefield whoop
his offensive drone flies around
attacking enemies while Saint his
defensive drone hangs back and heals
Wilhelm like a prune broom less talk
would say I would say that you can also
outfit will him with cybernetic
enhancements systems are a go
welcome to robot once sitting population
everyone's faces
neasha the lore bringer does not even
give a tandem up with her showdown skill
Nisha
automatically
Sanda nearby enemies and gets increased
everything goddamn inspiring reload
sweet
accuracy if she's pissed enough she can
clear out an entire room and only a few
seconds every time she takes damage she
also gains a stack of order if she gets
enough order nation can use aligning
with to do a yeah right bananas amount
of damage to the enemies in front of her
that's right
case you're like stealing paint just as
much as she likes receiving it which may
seem weird to you but doubt judge
whatever did you burn Athena that
gladiator is unstoppable what she pulls
out her kineticast this shield the more
enemies shooted aspis the more damage it
does once of inna holds it like a weapon
she can even upgrade it to ricochet off
multiple enemies Athena can also use a
saw to make enemies bleed if she didn't
grabs the you've got red on your skill
all bleeding enemies explode when they
die it he'll scientifically not messing
imaginable claptrap the frag trap is
shall we say chicken his bolt Hunter dot
exe program will analyze the battlefield
determine which vault hunter would be
best suited for blowing up all of its
problems right in and then reprogram
claptrap to fight in that particular
manner perhaps he'll unleash a barrage
of cannon fire on his enemies or maybe
he'll summon a spirit of the guns er a
dual wheel he might even unleash his
inner psycho and go into full-on meat
bicycle moon or if you mess up it just
make the entire team uncontrollably
bouncy it's not malware it's a feature
[ __ ] oh and this time round the bow
hunters will be much chattier Cathy's in
before like the fun kind of talk are the
dull kind this is so frigging hot well
the old ball tenors didn't have much to
say outside of combat these four new
badasses will have lots to say about the
story and their place in it I'm
programmed to be foolishly optimistic in
situations such as these why am I not
surprised
characters I see speaking of characters
you'll be seeing some new faces on a
plus in addition to some familiar ones
this is strange a super-nice strat
vendor with a super huge crush on Athena
this is nurse need who will keep you
alive but totally laughs when you're in
pain
also Maxie is on the mood for some
reason please but anyway Elvis requires
your help quite badly you see a number
of homicidal dole soldiers known as The
Lost Legion have taken over Hyperion's
orbital moon base and they plan to use
its enormous laser to destroy both Elvis
and Pandora only the vault hunters aided
by a lowly Hyperion programmer named
Jack and stop the lost legions commander
from killing thousands of innocent
people
which is weird cuz Jack will a monisha
in a big bad guys in Borderlands 2 so
it's like wait
am i a bad guy over the so called bad
guys not as bad as I thought
Farah land back given a taste an agent
at a Catholic mother bill this game is
also into you or looking into the heart
of darkness isn't your thing you can
still have a buttload of blood checking
at the new moon environments there's
lava stuff move some sexy caverns no big
deal also cities also be close on the
ground also all the cool stuff on
Hyperion Stelios new base that I can
mention in the preceding list hammerlock
talk
innovate or something of course many new
baddies he'll attempt to stop your
heroic efforts Lost Legion engineers
will deploy turrets and singularity
reactors to suck you it while you're
shooting at em a Lost Legion medic might
come in and heal them thus screwing up
all your plan later perhaps you'll run
into a beastly kraggen you'll kill it
but in but gracious you'll split into
two smaller Krakens who are equally
deadly what quirk of evolution resulted
in such a defense mechanism or better
question who cares why kind of learn
stuff when you could just read them over
with whether new moon vehicles their
physiology doesn't Casper but when
there's crunching under your wheels
we're burning under your hover Jets am i
right
you are not at all rides but please
continue for all the stuff that's new in
toast add everything you like before is
best for player color split screen item
trading badass Rick except now you can
show off your it to all your friends
tests of skills
multiple playthroughs head
customizations skin customizations
vehicle customization internet memes
Justin tweeted lead vocals inner beeps
those were awful our bad while such
means very regret it's nearly time you
badass with badasses The Lost Legion is
on the warpath and it's up to you in
check to save the world
grab a freeze gun by five your best
friend and get your ass to the moon
brother Lance the priest